[MUSIC]
As folks enter welcome
my name is Wil Torres.
I'm one of the admission officers at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
I am so excited to be hosting this
panel from Africa to Stanford.
Our goal today is to talk about all
of those things in that early stage
of the process.
How were you thinking
about business school?
What was the transition like?
What were those first few weeks like, and
how can we make sure that we're
providing as much information
to everybody out there on the different
journeys that people take to Stanford?
So that once they're here you're able to
thrive, eyes wide open and really reach
for those things that help you lead a life
of meaning and a career of purpose.
When you come to Stanford you're
going to be joining a global community.
In this year's graduating class of 2021,
Joshua, I see you,
congratulations on your
impending graduation.
We had 43% international students, so
it really is a community of
folks from all over the world.
This class represented 66 countries,
over 70 languages spoken.
Some of the most exciting things,
too, is what's happening.
How do we support some of these voices and
experiences, so that people are really
able to learn and engage across all
of these different lived experiences?
Clubs and organizations
are definitely a huge part of that.
For this crowd in particular, the Africa
Business Club might be of interest,
bringing together professional and
personal and community.
Regardless of where in the world
that you're thinking of going, and
especially for those thinking
about returning to the continent.
There's also our
Middle East North Africa Club,
bringing together a lot of folks
from the greater MENA region to
celebrate many of those destinations,
people and cultures.
There's an International Committee
in our student government,
as well as a DEI Council where
folks are able to get involved, and
a Bechtel International Center.
So Bechtel International Center serves
our greatest Stanford University, and
our pretty big international community.
So for everything from visa questions,
to internship opportunities,
they're going to be a great resource
to help direct you to all the different
needs that folks from international
backgrounds might be looking for
while they're at the GSB.
So let's go ahead and get started and
get to meet our panelists.
So we'll go from left to right.
You could tell us a little bit,
share your name, where you're from, and
a little bit about maybe one of your
favorite classes while you're at the GSB.
So Michelle,
if we can get started with you, please?
>> Sure, hi everyone,
really nice to be here today.
So my name is Michelle,
I'm originally from Kenya, but
I've been in the US for a while,
almost 15 years I think at this point.
So I first came here for undergrad,
I went to Haverford College,
and then I worked in New York,
in consulting and
in banking before applying
to business school.
A class that I really enjoyed while
I was at GSB, this one is going
to be a bit cliche but touchy feely,
I think is definitely up there.
It's more around, and I think that the
official name is Interpersonal Dynamics.
And so it's really around how you impact
others, how you provide feedback,
and how you essentially make
yourself more vulnerable so
you can form deeper relationships.
And it's something that I try to apply
both in my personal life as well as my
professional life.
So that's been, I think a class
that's had a lasting impact for me.
>> Yeah,
Michelle was there an A-ha moment or
a particular learning that
continues to sit with you today?
>> I think the easiest way to summarize my
takeaways from that class is you have to
be willing to open yourself up if you're
going to form deeper relationships with
people.
And I think especially coming from Kenya,
I think in a lot of African countries,
that's not necessarily
how we were brought up.
Especially in terms of like
how we share our emotions,
how you interact with leaders,
how you interact with older people.
But especially when you think
about the culture in the US,
even the corporate culture, a lot of it is
starting to move towards welcoming more of
that vulnerability in
the corporate workplace.
In the workplace in terms of
building leadership skills and
building relationships
across the organization.
So that's why I think
about that class a lot.
>> Thank you.
Abiodun, you can go ahead and
introduce yourself, please.
>> Hello, everyone.
My name is Abiodun Buhari,
I'm from Nigeria, and
then I actually had my undergrad
years at the University of Ibadan,
in Ibadan State, Nigeria.
So after that I did
industrial engineering, and
after that I worked a bit in Lagos,
all my career in Lagos prior to
Stanford GSB and
I applied directly from Lagos, Nigeria.
So I've never been to the US
prior to going to Stanford, so
Stanford took me to the US for
the very first time.
It was a beautiful experience, and
then at Stanford I think one class
I really found really interesting,
I found really interesting is managing and
growing enterprise.
And also scaling,
I think something around them,
scaling I impact ventures
in emerging markets.
Those two classes were
a bit really good for me.
The first one because
we actually deal with
real life issues that you could encounter
during growing your organization cliche.
The other one talks about Gujar,
it's more like startup garage,
allows you to develop an idea,
and then use yourself and
your classmates to actually
develop that idea in class,
and also go as far as testing
your ideas in markets.
So I worked on Ed tech then
because I had passion of trying
to use technology to deliver quality
education to less privileged, and
also that for me was also another class
I found really, really interesting.
So that's it for me for now.
Maybe Joshua can take it on.
>> Nice, yeah?
Joshua, take it away.
>> Thanks, Buhari.
Yeah, hi everyone.
Nice to meet you.
I'm Joshua.
Like Abiodun, my undergrad was in Nigeria.
But in the better school, Obafemi Awolowo
University, not quite 45 minutes away.
[LAUGH] So I was a clinician and
an academician in Kano.
So I worked at the Kano Teaching hospital
and lectured at the Bayero University.
And I had veered into public health
earlier in such a broad impact,
and then realized that I also
wanted to focus on contributing to
capital allocating decisions, because
that would even allow me further impact.
Which is why I decided to apply for
the MBA.
So I applied again from Nigeria From Kano,
so not Lagos like the other.
Classes that I've enjoyed it at the GSB,
where do I start?
I know I'm forced to pick just one.
And I've enjoyed many of the classes that
Michelle and Biodun have spoken about.
But I think one that
stands out to me is OSM.
So the optimization and
simulation modeling.
I've always loved numbers.
I had to forget about
those becoming a doctor.
Not really, but I guess now I had to
engage with it in a more germaine manner.
But I think what actually resonated
with me was the fact that,
if you really think deeply about it,
you can convert almost every qualitative
problem to a quantitative issue.
And that actually helps
me decision making.
And that has flowed into
a course I'm taking now.
Corporate financial
modelling with demersal,
which I absolutely love because
it brings the qualitative and
quantitative part of business together and
makes it real for you.
So I'd say that's the streak that
I've enjoyed a lot here at Stanford.
>> All right, and then you are thinking
about going from the healthcare
world to the finance world, right?
Yes, so I said,
I have gone into public health,
hoping to affect the socioeconomic
determinants of disease,
not just the symptoms of the diseases I
was treated but realized very quickly
that everything that should be paid for
and the current impact models we had.
A lot is philanthropy or policy or
waiting for capital markets to efficiently
distribute resources and be able to
tackle things like climate change and
co, I realized that it
was just ineffective.
So the fastest way to do that would be for
somebody like me,
who had policy competencies,
who have worked in government,
who have worked in non-profits world,
to actually be where capital
allocation decisions were being made,
and that literally means finance.
So yes, I do hope to end up in development
finance stroke impact investing someday,
and that's why I came for
the MBA program, yeah.
>> All right, so
I'm going to stop sharing screen, so
we'll be able to focus on each other.
And so, folks continue to submit
questions, one of you, so
you say you are already beating me
to the punch with my first question.
And so, I'm going to ask it through the
lens of our Q and A box here, Joshua says,
thank you very much for the session.
So thank you all our panellists for
joining us.
For Abiodun, maybe we can start
with you with this question.
And then for our other panelists,
I'll ask you follow up some
with a slight adjustments.
But how difficult was it to adapt to life
in the US, especially in those first days,
given that, you just mentioned this
was the first time you came to the US?
>> Well, at first, I came with the zeal
of if I can succeed in Nigeria,
I think I can succeed [LAUGH]
anywhere in the world.
I came with that mentality.
But to be very honest, the very first
few days were a bit challenging,
I have to put it out there.
Challenging because there
were language barrier,
not in terms of the fact that maybe
understanding of English but more around
the accents to which people around and
even the professors was speaking.
So, I find it difficult to
understand really deeply what,
I find it difficult to
flow in class a bit.
So, it was a bit challenging,
plus the fact that the volume of
materials I have to read
[LAUGH] to each class is really
voluminous compared to how we
used to study back in Nigeria.
So, it was really challenging, but
then I think what got you into Stanford
in the first place is the fact
that you have the ability to
definitely improve in no time.
And with support of the the student,
what do you call it now?
The Student Support Service part
of GSB we're really helpful in
the sense that that we have to do focus
groups, for example, where people speak,
and then if I don't understand,
I tell them to slow down a bit and
then I get the message, and
they were really helpful.
Within that same quarter, I was able
to definitely get myself on track back,
but the first few days
were a bit challenging.
One was accent shock I'll say, and
then the other one is the volume of
work that you have to go through, and
then also the fact that
the lifestyle is a bit different.
I was used to, for example, local
foods coming from Nigeria, [LAUGH] and
then you have to go to to go and be eating
pizza, and burger, and all that every day.
So that was another very huge
difference I have to try to adjust to.
So those were the experiences
that in the early days,
but I think they pretty much set me up for
success eventually.
Thank you.
>> So you mentioned some of
the students support and actually,
Joshua, you are one of our peer mentors.
Can you tell us and
tell us a little bit about that program?
And then I'll come back to what your
transition felt like coming to the GSB.
>> Sure, I can do that.
So, I think that thinking behind
the peer mentor program is that peer
to peer support can be oftentimes highly
effective when it comes to tackling
sometimes common concerns but
sometimes even more esoteric ones.
And somebody who has walked in
the shoes that you are going to feel is
may be able to give you cogent ideas and
advice on tackling some of these things.
And so
I was selected along with 11 other awesome
people to be peer mentors
by the 2021 long session,
and I personally interacted with,
say around 35
mentees because we were two
peer mentors per section,
and then each section had 70 people.
So, I'd say we were able to
develop a deep connection,
sometimes deep friendships.
I was able to help with
advice concerning academics,
concerning our interaction
with all other classmates,
with those in MBA two networks,
career searches,
and just generally be a resource whenever
the incoming student wanted
to tap on that resource.
The program has been
reformatted a little bit, but
it still remains, and
I think that the reformatting
is going to position for
even greater expert.
So that's actually great resource for
those coming from
more different context to the GSB to
be able to tap into using to academics.
>> Nice, and then Joshua, you had multiple
[LAUGH] other graduate experiences.
How would you compare the GSB and Business
School to some of those experiences?
because I know some folks in our
attendees group might also becoming
from other graduate programs.
That is such an interesting question.
And for context, I completed
the graduate program in medicine,
so I completed the Residency and
then Fellowships after that,
I also started,
don't know if I'm going to complete a PhD.
That was somewhere in Netherlands, and
then I have a masters in Public Health,
from the East Coast.
The school that's spelled
Stanford backwards.
So, yes, I do have quite
a few graduates experiences,
some say its too much school.
How Stanford and
the Business School compares to it,
I'd say very briefly and
maybe this is recency bias speaking.
But if I could go along
maybe some attributes,
I'd say in terms of, one, inclusivity,
I think that Stanford does
a wonderful job of being
very intentional on how to
create community within and
even outside what you'd
consider your normal bubble.
Two, I think Stanford does a good job of
accommodating different learning styles.
Many of the other places I was in
it's either the way or the highway.
But here, there's a huge focus
of multidisciplinary learning,
some are using seminar style format,
they're using didactic.
Are you a visual learner,
are you a more verbal learner,
in Stanford there's
a very good job of that.
Three, the sheer amount of resources here,
I think, is unrivaled, worldwide.
And that might be on a per capita basis
because they invest in smaller class size.
But I do think the choice of classes is
also intentional to be able to ensure
that you're almost buried in resources,
and that's fantastic.
And if you're coming from Africa like
me and you don't really like cold,
there's something to be said about
the wonderful weather in California.
Yeah, so, I could go on and on.
But this just gives you a sense of how
I think Stanford compares to many of
the other programs that I've been in.
I think many people could
learn from Stanford.
>> And then, Michelle,
you did your undergrad here in the US.
Did your undergrad compared to
a graduate program knowing that you went
to Haverford, a liberal arts college
in Philadelphia on the East Coast.
Can you talk a little bit about how
those two experiences might compare and
what this folks, who might also be
attending a small liberal arts school
could expect coming to
a school like the GSB.
>> Yeah, so, it's funny.
I'm trying to think back and it makes
me feel like it was like, decades ago,
[LAUGH] this is funny.
But I think the biggest difference is,
well,
maybe let me start with the similarities.
I think the similarities is
Haverford was a pretty small school.
So, overall, the entire student body
was something like 1,000 students.
GSB each class is about 400, so,
times three you are getting about 800.
So the size of the communities
are pretty similar.
But I think what I would say
the biggest differences are is one,
when you go into undergrad, you're just
at a different point in your life, right?
You're probably, that's the first time
maybe you've left your parents home and so
it's a very foreign environment for
a lot of people.
I think even the people who are maybe
based locally, it's like the first time
you're really in a different
environment from your home environment.
And so, I remember for me because that
was my first time coming to Kenya,
it was very similar to Abiodun.
I think that's when I had to deal with
the issues around like accents and
being heard and getting used to the class
environment, how grading is done here,
the relationships that you
have with your professor,
that's why I think I had my culture shock.
And so as a result I think when I went
into Business School, it didn't feel
as much of a tough transition
as I think undergrad did for me.
I think the other difference that I
would call out is because you're sort
of in a different point in your life,
right?
When you get into Business School,
you have some work experience.
For a lot of people you've worked,
anywhere between two to four years, you've
been out in the world, you've essentially
earned your own money in some cases.
And so
your approach to both the academic and
social environment in
Business School is very different.
So Business School is a lot more social.
It's a lot more network-focused.
It's a lot more focused around how you're
building longer term relationships with
your classmates.
Whereas I think undergrad is more academic
in nature, in terms of the focus.
And so, I think at the end of the day,
what I enjoyed about both experiences is,
because they're small, you do have that
closeness that Joshua mentioned, right?
The community, the inclusiveness.
But because you're at different points in
your life, what you get out of a business
school environment is, I think,
more longer term in terms of your network,
and your career than probably undergrad,
just based on my experience.
>> Nice, and then so this next question
maybe we can start with you, as well,
Michelle.
So the question comes from Kashira,
who has a question about the MBA
experience, how did it change or
impact your perception of how
you view business in Africa?
Earlier you mentioned some of
the different cultural elements and
how you interact with others.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about that Michelle, and
then we'll open it up to the panel.
>> Yeah, so I would say one of the reasons
I actually was really excited to go to
Stanford once I got in is because, I
think Stanford is one of the few business
schools in the US that is taking a very,
let's call it,
mature partnership type of approach to
how they think about African businesses.
And I think we see this both
in terms of the classes.
So there's a lot of, just case studies
that are focused on African countries.
I remember my first strategy
class was on Equity Bank,
which is one of the biggest
banks in Kenya.
There's a lot of classes focused around
how you navigate some of the tougher sort
of regulatory environments that we tend
to see in a lot of African countries,
as well.
And then, of course,
there is the Seed Network.
That is a program at Stanford
that works directly to support
building leadership and
business skills with African companies.
And they have a presence,
I believe, in Ghana.
They have a presence in Kenya, and
they work with a cohort
of companies every year.
And so, being able to tap into
all of those resources during
my Business School experience,
for me, was fantastic.
Because even though I hadn't necessarily
spent a lot of time working on
the continent, it gave me a sense for what
that could look like, because I'm learning
more about the ins and outs of strategy
making within African countries,
exploring these regulatory environments.
And then with the Seed Network,
specifically,
I had a chance to do an internship
with a Nigerian company.
So, I was able to work with a Nigerian
makeup company the summer between first
and second year.
Which was just a fantastic
experience because, one,
you are kind of then in the heart
of a business on the continent.
You get to see the ins and outs,
you get to see the challenges, and
you get to learn from the most
senior leaders in that company.
And so, before Business School,
the idea of, let's say,
moving back home and engaging in
business was in my mind, I think,
being able to then explore that fully
within the Business School experience In
class as well as like on the ground within
internships made it a lot more real.
So that as I think about long term
what could moving back home look like?
I feel like I have a much better
understanding now versus before where it
was, I think a lot more theoretical.
>> Yeah, speaking of moving back home,
we have someone who did it on the panel.
So, maybe Abiodun can you tell us
a little bit about like, did the GSB.
How did that shape your view of
kind of working back on the continent?
And how does it continue to
kind of impact your work today?
>> So I tell you the so
currently I'm special assistant
to the Ogun state governor.
His excellency,
Governor Mallam Ahmad El-Rufai's and
I basically focus on economic matters.
I feel just believe it set me up for
success in that aspect.
So while at GSB, I focused a lot
more on the social innovation.
I took a lot of shine abroad classes and
I and the certificate for
public management and social innovation.
So that set me up for
that line of my line of my career.
And after grad actually what is
between US with a Fintech company.
And then even while working there,
I was very open to doing
something that impacts like
the continent directly.
I went there, I knew the opportunity was
going to come, was only a matter of time.
So when it came down,
I just grabbed it and i moved back.
And the governor actually, also assured
me of things are going to be fine.
I'm going to be able to walk on programs
that can really see the impact.
And a lot of that can actually
accomplished a little more.
And what Stanford MBA is
still doing right now for me.
My career is setting me apart from
every other person around to be honest.
I have a better understanding of problems.
I have better idea generation system.
And I also shown out like
really quality word has been
talked about in every part
of the governor's office.
So pretty much try to put you in
a position where you can actually go far.
Not only in business, but
in other parts of the areas that
you may eventually choose to go to.
For example, we are classes which
are beyond the market class for example.
I give you an idea of what really
is the role of government for
non market state actors.
In ensuring the success of businesses
in a particular territory.
So for me for now, if I related
with In a couple of businesses.
So for example, we're just building
this very huge mall in town.
And they will have to really get investors
like retail stores and all that.
And I really have to work with
them to ensure that they succeed.
They actually set up upon and succeed.
Because that's where you get the benefit.
And a lot of hour I was able to do that
was from the class life for example.
Beyond the market class
that we did at Stanford.
So, really you give me
the awareness that as a government.
Your role is not just step
on business environment.
But to enable them to grow and
then nourish them to become
billion dollar brands around.
So it's been a really interesting
experience working back home.
And I've actually opened even
a lot more doors to be honest.
So for example, they actually got
admitted to the MPP program at Oxford.
And the government is sponsoring
my attending the Masters in
Public Policy Program at Sam University,
Oxford, for example.
So these are the things that
you get benefits from based
on the fact that they
know that you're capable.
That they just want to set you up for
success ongoing on that particular part.
So that's the it's been really
great experience for me so far.
>> And Abiodun you mentioned
the certificate in public management.
We have a question here from Grace about.
How does Stanford support folks, who are
looking to work in the nonprofit world?
So I can share a couple of resources.
And then we'll open it up to the panel for
how they've seen people
working in the nonprofit.
Social impact space kind of
taking shape on campus.
We do offer a loan forgiveness program for
folks who are working
in the nonprofit space.
So that is a wonderful opportunity
to really think about.
How can I be a leader in any
field that I'm interested in?
Especially that nonprofit space.
And not have to worry too much about.
Like, what does that
debt burden look like?
How am I going to pay it back?
We need leaders in all fields regardless
of what potential incomes make.
Another really great resource is
our center for social innovation.
And so they are a one wonderful how
far different resources programs,
alumni networks.
That can really get you connected and even
provide additional sources of funding,
internship opportunities and
connections and networking.
To help accelerate your career and
have fun.
And so we are dropping a couple of links
in the chat as we speak about those
resources.
But for anyone on the group, can you talk
a little bit more about like how you've
seen folks interested in impact.
Or kind of making that change in
the world come to life on campus.
>> I can offer a couple of examples.
So I think beyond what you talked about in
terms of the center of social innovation.
I think, for graduating MBA to students,
they also have a chance to apply for
a fellowship.
I want to say it's the Africa fellowship,
maybe it's the wrong one.
So you might need to look at
whether it's the right one.
But there is a fellowship available for
those that are interested in starting
their own social innovation ventures.
And it helps to fund I think
a year of operations for
the person to kind of
explore the model set it up.
And so one of my classmates took advantage
of that set up a financial literacy and
savings platform.
Targeted at lower income
individuals here in the US.
And so he was able to get a lot
of support from that program.
For this from the center of social
innovation to get this venture up and
running.
For the last several years.
So that's the example I threw out there.
And, again, if I'm calling you
the wrong thing, please correct me.
But I think that's what
it's called [LAUGH].
>> And then Josh,
I saw you hop on as well.
>> Yeah, I guess I could jump in there.
I was actually going to mention
the Africa group fellowship.
So yes, you got to name correctly.
I think currently there's
also both a chime
fellowship that supports social ventures.
They actually just a lot, so
in terms of the curriculum
that supports you to be able to think
through what you actually want to do.
And refine both strategy.
Your mission and
then in terms of practical experiences.
So actually allow you to test
out some of your theories.
In terms of connection to alumni who have
gone before you in many of these pathways.
You are definitely not going to be
left alone with any of these ideas.
I think Stanford's change lives, change
organizations, change the world, just.
Comes to mind here, the elite talk, so
if you're interested in social innovation,
I actually do think this
is the place to be.
>> And so we talk a lot about coming to
the GSB, looking for what's coming next.
I think something that is also really
important that is very special
to individuals is how do you
maintain the connections and
relationships with the people you
had before coming to the GSB?
So here is a question from Fatogo about
how did you manage to stay in contact with
your friends and family and
your home countries,
even with a significant time difference?
Any tips, recommendations,
reflections on how you were able
to maintain those connections?
>> Maybe I'll start with mine
because mine is more recent than
the other panelists and
then they could jump on.
I think almost everything in
life when you want something,
you just need to dedicate a little
bit of effort and time to it,
I will not lie,
it is sometimes incredibly isolating.
And especially in Africa where we
have morphe coming out culture,
where I was used to just walking down
the road just knocking on my friends door.
And kicking it in and saying,
hey, I want to sit on your couch,
serve me, I don't want to cook you
feed me today, just stuff like that.
So this is a very different atmosphere,
we're more calendar driven here and
you actually quite,
they have quite a lot
of deliverables to do.
So, in terms of how I have kept in touch
by reckoning with the time difference and
maybe setting a pattern out to before bed.
When I can actually, yeah,
just call people that I want to
speak to even scheduling those
conversations beforehand.
I had to embrace other social media means,
I'm not the heavy social media user,
in fact, I tend to want to
detoxify from it regularly.
But I've realized that some people
are more accessible on Facebook,
some people are more accessible by
Instagram and blah, blah, blah.
And so
I literally had to embrace it just so
that I could keep in touch
with my second zone.
And then sometimes just
a basic text message.
I think when upstairs makes the how
to grow fund and I think even for
you who is a part people on the continent
your community will be thinking
more of you because they think hey,
you're in a different place and
corn, so anytime you just hear
from you is just fantastic.
So curious to hear if Michelle and
Abiodun tried other
means of maintaining connections
with their communities.
>> No, I think you hit on all
of all of them, I will say,
I think things have just gotten so
much easier with WhatsApp and
just being able to do
WhatsApp calls in most cases.
As long as data is cheap and
free in your home country.
I think it's probably been a much easier
way for me to stay in touch with my family
nowadays versus for
example when I was in undergrad.
When you had to buy a scratch
card [LAUGH] and you get $10 and
if you call in 10 minutes [LAUGH] so
I think the technology in terms of
staying in touch has definitely improved.
So everything that Joshua mentioned,
I think it makes it that much easier,
we just have to be intentional
about finding the time to
connect with your family and
friends back home.
>> Well, I think I don't have
to repeat what Joshua and
Michelle said,
I think it's the same for me too,
just that because most time,
almost every time I'm homesick,
I visited Nigeria a couple of times during
my program just also to stay in touch.
And there are so many support,
travel support that I can get from
school to actually do districts,
and then I think I'll be able
to leverage a couple of one or
two of them in terms of getting subsidized
ticket to Nigeria and all of that.
So I did Daniel's a program that also took
me to add, I think is the seat program.
They also took me to Africa and
I used opportunity also visit Nigeria, so
you get those opportunity too, in addition
to staying in touch with your family.
Via WhatsApp internet is free and
everywhere at Stanford so
you don't have any problem to
connecting to your family or anything.
Like Michelle has said now things
are getting really better,
internet data is becoming
really cheap now.
Even on the other side, which is Africa,
the flow of communication
should not be as much troubling
as it used to be in the past.
>> And focusing on today's
topic from Africa to Stanford,
we have a question here
from Airy about what
you think were some of your
contributions to the GSB community?
And if relevant, how does elements
of your African identity,
how might that have contributed or
what are some of the perspectives?
Any thoughts or experiences on times that
you've seen kind of that side show up and
contribute to what was
going on at the moment?
>> I think I can chip in on this, I know
that a couple of classes where a lot
of the cases that we're doing with pretty
much I can focus in on another region.
And then a lot of the conclusion are very
different from what you would want
obtainable on the continent, for example.
So, you coming in as an African to chip
into the class, and say, wow this is
brilliant, but it is a bit a different
world entirely where I come from.
And then getting them to know
about this new experience that
is not obtainable in most part of the
world is really really, really fulfilling.
And it also gets them to really be very
interested in Africa, for example,
as I can really recall I
think one of the classes
we're doing we're out to do with
social immigration financing.
And I was so hoping that we were
doing the conversation was around
financing social innovation in,
I think was India something.
But then the case was totally,
if you put that in context of Nigeria,
for example, actually, for my experience
we walk in with a low income environment.
It was a bit different on how
to give that perspective and
it became full blown conversation
in the class afterwards.
So these are waves which you can actually
show your experience of being African
in class, there are other
ways to which you can do it.
The Africa Business School, for example,
organizes the Africa Business Forum every
year, and then you get to participate.
Use your network to invite really
interesting speakers to the panels and
also the program the keynote speakers for
the forum itself and
then people from other continents.
I had a lot of my friends from everypart
part of the word coming for the forum and
actually gaining so much from
the speakers that probably they will
not have encountered if not for
the ABF conference, for example.
So at least those are the two
ways I can think of right now,
maybe Joshua I'm sure can
also chip in on that.
One of my favorite tools in conversations
like those case studies, or the workroom
like, I have a different perspective is,
yes and, [LAUGH] jumping in that way.
So Michelle, go ahead.
>> Yeah, I think Abiodun gave a lot of
great examples of how you bring your
experiences, your network into
the classroom into the campus environment.
I think the other way is essentially
connecting people to your classmates or
even your professors to
people on the continent,
depending on what they're working on.
So let's say for example,
they're looking to do a case on a company
on the continent in a specific sector.
A lot of times they'll reach
out to students either through
the Africa Business Club or
just generally to just say, hey,
what companies should we be working with,
should we be partnering with?
If people are looking for internships on
the continent that's another way that,
depending on the country
that they're interested in,
you can also offer perspective,
you can offer introduction.
And then the last piece, I think this
was probably more pre-Covid, but
maybe we'll come back post-Covid,
is all the DST.
So these are the global study
trips that [LAUGH] Abiodun,
I guess you enjoyed one of those because
the way you're so excited [LAUGH].
But these are essentially trips
that happen every semester
that students organize and as a group,
you decide which countries you
want to expose your classmates to.
So, during I think my second year
a group of students organized a trip to,
I want to say Uganda and Rwanda.
There's been trips to,
I want to say Kenya and South Africa.
There is I think been interest
in organizing trips in Nigeria.
I don't know if it ever happened Abiodun,
please call me [LAUGH].
>> Yes it did.
>> Finally it did, that's amazing.
>> Yeah, it did.
>> Awesome.
Yeah, so that's another great way I think
as African students where you're able to
really showcase what business means on
the continent, what leadership means
on the continent, to your classmates, who
otherwise would not have that exposure.
>> I guess there's not much to add.
I can echo everything Abiodun and
Michelle have said.
But to that I'll also add that
there's a culture of small
group dinners here at the GSB.
And to the extent you'd like to cook,
you could actually
just invite people to get
a taste of Africa from you and
you might also be willing to screen one or
two movies you
feel very typical depictive
of your reality in Africa.
It's also this was something that
happened in my first year and
I think a lot of people took a lot
of learnings away from that.
So that's also something
that you could add.
So there are just many ways
by which you can actually
contribute to the GSB
community as an African.
>> Now you are making me miss GSB so
much right now.
There is also the part, there's this
international food day or something.
>> Yeah
>> Where you get cooked food from
a different part of the world.
I still remember my plantain that fried,
its the bare fact.
People were literally coming
to me to try it again.
So it's so
much fun being an African at the GSB.
You don't even have an idea at all.
Like now I'm missing GSB be so bad.
I think I should visit sometime soon.
>> You better come back and
you're going to make me some plantains and
I hope you gotta teach me because
I love some good plantain.
>> Dont worry, I got you a lot.
>> Yes
>> Actually building something you
made me, you're totally right.
I think it's a lot of fun being
an African on the continent.
And I think a lot of it is you're meeting
so many people from all over the world,
but you're meeting a lot
of other Africans.
And guys we are so much fun.
Whether it's like within
the Africa business club events,
whether it's just hanging out.
Whether it's just being able to just
relax and talk in whatever accent without
necessarily people wondering
if they can hear you.
There is I think a big enough community
that's been built over time where you just
have accents of home and sense of comfort
that, maybe you're on a day-to-day basis,
when you're in classes,
when you're in other experiences,
you don't necessarily have that.
But I feel like the at least, when I was
at GSB the African community was pretty
tight knit where you really felt like it
was essentially you're pleased to come and
relax and just kick it and just be
comfortable with your fellow Africans.
So,
>> Don't let us also forget to mention
Centre for Africa studies,
just in case you've seen so
much of your GSB, African brothers.
You can actually go to the Center for
African Studies where you meet Africans
that undergrad, mostly another
post grad come together to have immunity
discussing everything about Africa.
It's also like a really good resource
where you can meet Africans in
the larger Stanford community
at any particular place.
They do programs,
invite people from the continent
to speak on different topics also.
And then Joshua,
I see jumped on here there's a question,
I think can be really helpful as people
are getting excited about the GSB and
kind of comparing, especially if
they're educated on the continent.
How do you engage in some of these
conversations in the classroom in a way
that's productive and constructive.
>> Yeah I was just going to take there.
That is actually what is expected.
The GSB does not just argue for
diversity and
inclusion just as a catchphrase,
I suppose one but
because it research shows that
it actually leads to better
decisions of better,
some more creativity, all of that.
And the whole essence of going for
a diverse class is to ensure
that there's a diversity of opinions
when issues are being discussed.
So as long as you are cognizant
of the impact of your words and
those listening to it,
you are expected and
invited to challenge any
notions that you disagree with.
It takes some learning, really differently
from our roots learning system in Nigeria,
I guess a lot of Africa, but
after some time you get the hang of it.
You're well smart people,
you got into Stanford after all.
So it doesn't take a few weeks,
you might need to refine and
sometimes choose your battle
because sometimes you realize
that the point you are trying to
make has been made already, or
you are literally killing
a dead horse with more guns.
But, yeah, it's something that
Stanford actually invites.
>> I also like to mention
this experience I had.
So back in Nigeria, and
I'm sure Joshua can attest to this,
you dare not probably talk back
at your professor in class.
All you probably do take note of all
of these things and then shifting from
that perspective to where you actually is
scored for having really good conversation
in class is also like another one I
had to struggle with at the beginning.
I have to automation that.
It was, in fact I had to go and
have one on one sessions with
the professors to say, okay,
how do you do that and do it really well?
So it's something you also have to
have at the back of the mind if you
are coming to GSB.
That a, leave all of those you
can't approach professors.
Yeah, they're going to be, we have
professors who invest in students I guess.
So it can go as far as that.
So you're going into a cultural where
you must have really good conversation
with your professors.
At that conversation in class where
students literally change professor's
perspective on what he's teaching.
It was so smooth and what was happening
to him was really very encouraging for
the classes, so
you should be hooked on and off.
Have the mind that you're going into
one have really good conversation and
form relationship and friendship with
your professors rather than having also,
relationship with them.
>> Thank you, oftentimes there's
like a small like learning tips and
experiences and like expectations
that don't always get conveyed.
So that was, I think,
going to be really helpful for
folks regardless of what schools
they might end up that year.
And so I am actually going to claim
the honor of the last question,
we are getting close on time.
As you put yourself back in your shoes of
being an applicant to business school.
What advice would you give
to your younger self,
whether it is about the application or
even about business school?
Any advice that you would
give your younger self and
Joshua, maybe we can start with you.
>> .Max is actually very interesting.
So the way I thought about it, reading up
all of the resources on business school,
I decided that there are four categories
of people coming to business school.
One, they are career switchers,
two they are career optimizers.
So people who don't need business
school to go up in their careers, but
Business School sort of like
adds a little salt and flavor.
Think of maybe people in private equity
who are going back to private equity.
And then there are those who are finding
their career so courage Females.
Especially entrepreneurs, who know they
have the entrepreneurial drive, but
don't have it put out,
yet, something like that.
And then there are career advances,
those who advance their career, so
maybe think of those who are in
healthcare administration.
And want to become the CFO
of some healthcare company.
So I think I was a curious return.
So I was puberty and so
my advice would probably apply this
to those that are switching careers.
And it is come with an open mind, you are
almost going to be starting from scratch.
And to certain extent you're even
two years post business school,
you're still going to be in business.
You're still going to be learning
a lot about the new place.
So, basically, the mindset you had
when you were in college when you
could absorb a lot more information.
Listen more rather than respond,
find the best ways to absorb
information and process it.
I'd say that's the mindset
you should come with me.
But with regards to the application
process itself, I think the most important
advice I'd give is to start early and
fail forward and feel quickly.
So the more you easier, there is, the more
chances you have to get it correctly.
But if you allow analysis to paralyze you,
then suddenly you've wasted
a year just thinking, how can I?
Am I, at the end of the day,
you want to be able to get it done?
As far as I'm concerned,
if you're thinking about business today,
you should be applying to business school.
So I guess that's my piece of advice,
hope it's helpful.
>> Shall we go next, please?
>> Yeah, I think I will,
I'll build on what Joshua said.
And I think the most,
important first take,
the first step that you have
to take is actually apply.
So I think it's really easy to get into
your head and to have a lot of doubts and
to think that.
The only people who get into GSB or any of
these top schools are like super geniuses.
And I don't think I'm a super genius.
Maybe Joshua,
I believe you guys are super geniuses.
But, [LAUGH] at the end of the day,
like if you don't give yourself the shot,
right?
If you don't apply, essentially
taking yourself out of the game
before you've even been considered, so
I think it's normal to have doubts.
It's normal to think that some of
these schools are out of our range and
out of our reach.
But you have to overcome that and
just put in the application,
put your best foot forward.
And you might be surprised
when you actually get in.
So I think that's the first thing.
The second thing in terms of
just the mindset of applying.
I really like how Joshua put it,
[LAUGH] I like those different categories.
I think I could see myself,
[LAUGH] in one of them.
But for me, that the other important thing
about business school is you have to think
long term.
So it's really easy to think
about is this experience going
to help me get into this job after right.
After business school, or
is it going to help me start a company
right after Business School?
Is it that straight linear path?
And a lot of times in life
things are not linear and so
you have to think long term in
terms of both the application.
But also in terms of the choice of
school that you want to attend and
the experience that you end up
having there in the sense of.
And this goes back to what I mentioned in
the beginning a lot about business school
is the relationships that you form and
the network that you build.
And that's really what's
going to carry you for
the rest of your career regardless
of which industry you end up in.
With, regardless of whether
you end up working for
a corporate employer or
starting your own company.
I'm five years out of
business school right now and
the number of times I've been able to
tap into my alumni network both from
my class as well as other classes.
To move and navigate different,
across different companies,
is more than I can count.
So that's the other piece to keep
in mind with business school is,
think long term in terms of
the value when I get from it.
It's not necessarily just that person
job or first step out of business school
is long term if I think I
want to move back to Africa.
If I think I want to, go to Europe if I
think I want to start my own company.
Is this experience going to set me up for
that?
And if the answer is yes,
then it's going to be worthwhile.
>> Thank you, and
are we all doing take us home.
>> Yes, okay, so
I think I do have much to say you said
almost everything is out and out.
Another part of it is the buckets
that are just recreated,
we can actually do two at the same time.
Because I felt like I need to accent
I switch, so depends on what yeah.
When you want to take a mobile phone for
me,
surprising applies to refer back
to what matters most to me.
I literally just wrote out my last and
if I may like what really?
I remember crying and writing my essays.
So, our advice that you should
do internal reflection.
It should be from your heart, like I still
remember to people give me feedback and
say this essay will not get you started.
But because I hear,
let it be from your heart.
Let me try it,
if it doesn't work then fine and
then He worked, I had once and it worked.
So for a lot of the process Tran
internalized a lot of these
questions that will be asked.
And just purely from your heart,
you are unique.
You're just one person in the class, so
you, and for you to have been accepted.
You're bringing in a very unique
perspective into the class.
So try and thinking what goes through
because somebody said to you, right,
you wrote this essay in this fashion.
That's how you will do it.
No, that's not how,
it's being your true self.
So bringing your true selves
into the application matters on.
I think the other part is also like you
said, the alumni network is unbelievable.
Even in Africa, for example, we have
young and vibrant alumni really doing
really good things in and I'm sure if
I start mentioning a lot of them a lot
of people will relate to them,
to viewers to see your father is one.
I'm sure everybody knows [INAUDIBLE] in
Nigeria you definitely look Ethiopia too.
I think you should know tiger.
Like you have them [INAUDIBLE]
cannot feel rich on is
there really good stuff in
financial analysis apps.
I know a lot of them.
Tammi just build like one of the state
hospital in Lekki Lagos evercare.
I'm sure a lot of people will know
evercare in Lagos, she's also an alumni.
So these people are there as a resource
for you to explore, for sure.
And I'm trying to what Michelle said,
whether you're thinking of going back to
Africa, whether you're thinking of even
starting your own company in Africa.
They're there for you to use.
I've reached out to them,
as early on when I was trying to
navigate a particular government work.
Yeah, and I have to reach out to them.
I have to say,
I know you sat on this policy
deliberation before I did you got it go.
And he was able to advise me and I
literally put all of that in the document
and wild everybody that actually
listened to what I was saying.
So these are the things we
can get from the network.
So I think I'll handle that.
>> Thank you so much to our panelists.
I had the honor of having a great time.
Thank you so
much to all of our attendees regardless of
where in the world you're tuning in from.
It was a wonderful opportunity to
share time and space with you.
We hope to see you over
the course of the summer.
We have a ton of different events,
focus on different
topics related to your journey,
your application, and your Stanford.
So with that, have a wonderful evening and
I hope to see you all again soon.
Take care.
[MUSIC]